NOW IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
FATHER'S DAY IS SUNDAY SO
LET'S GIVE THE GIFT OF MUSIC
WITH TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
FATHER'S DAY BANDS.
EXAMPLES-- OH, LOOK AT THIS
UNEXPECTED TURN OF EVENTS.
SOMEONE IS VERY SURPRISED
BY THAT.
>> THATS WITH A VERY FATHER
ACTION.
>> OH, WE GET OUR OWN
HASHTAG GAME?
ALSO WHAT IS A HASHTAG?
(LAUGHTER)
>> EXAMPLES WOULD BE DADFINGER
-- THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
>> YES T DOES.
>> USUALLY.
>> OR THE CURE FOR ERECTILE
DYSFUNCTION THOSE ARE DAD
BANDS, 60 SECONDS, GO.
>> JIMMY PARDO.
>> CIALIS COOPER.
>> WONDERFUL, POINTS.
>> MUMFORD.
>> WELL PLAYED, POINTS. ALI
WONG.
>> NAT KING COLONOSCOPY.
>> YES, GOOD ONE.
>> THAT WOULD DEFINITELY BE
UNFORGETABLE. JIMMY.
>> STEVIE RAY VAUGHNMOWER.
>> POINTS.
>> JIMMY [BLEEP] PARDO.
>> IS MY BUTTON EVEN WORKING.
>> NO IT'S NOT.
>> I CAME TO PLAY, BABY.
DINOSAUR SENIOR.
>> YES, GOOD. POINTS. IAN, BUZZ
IN!
>> SLY AND THE FAMILY
STATION WAGON.
>> YES GOOD, OF COURSE. JIMMY.
>> LA-Z-BOY II MEN.
>> THE STROKE.
GOOD JOB, POINTS.
>> PAT BOONE BONE AND
HARMONY.
>> ALI.
>> THE ROLLING KIDNEY STONES.
>> YEP. IAN EDWARDS.
>> IF I CAN GET MY HAND ON
THE KID WITHOUT KEEPS
SMASHING PUMPKINS.